we are asked what fraction is located at
point a on the number line and we can
see point a right there
pause this video and see if you can
answer that
all right now there's a bunch of ways
that you could think about it you could
see that the space between zero and one
is split into
one
two
three
four equal spaces
and this has gone three of those four
equal spaces from zero to one so that's
one interesting way to think about it
another thing that might help us is a
bit of a visualization
if this rectangle represents a hole and
notice it goes from zero to one so you
could view one as a whole we have split
it into four equal sections so each of
these equal sections you would consider
a fourth so that's a fourth right over
there that's another fourth right over
there this is another fourth right over
there so how many of these fourths have
been shaded in well three of them have
been shaded in and when you look at the
number line you see the same idea
when we see the space between zero and
one it has been split into fourths so
this is a fourth and then another fourth
and then another fourth and another
fourth and where is point a well we have
gone 1 4 2 4
3 4
past 0 or from 0 to 1 which is a whole
so what fraction is located at point a
on the number line 3
4.
let's do another example
so here
we're told which point is at 2 6 on the
number line
pause this video and see if you can
answer on your own before we work
through it together and i'll give you a
little bit of a hint let's imagine that
this rectangle represents a hole and
notice it is divided into six equal
sections so each of those sections is a
sixth and so if i start at zero how many
would i fill in to get 2 6 and what
would be the corresponding point on the
number line
all right let's do it together
so if each of these is a 6th and we have
6 6 there so that would be a whole and
that's good because it goes from 0 to 1
and you could view 1 as a whole
2 6 is
so that's 1 6 right over there and then
that is 2 6.
and so you could see on the number line
the thing that gets us
2 6 of the way to 1 is at point b it
corresponds to how much we've filled up
that rectangle point b right over there
now another way that you could think
about it you could see that the space
between zero and one is split up into
six equal sections one
two three
four
five six equal sections and we want to
go to 2 6
to 6. so each of those equal sections we
are increasing by a sixth so we're going
from 0 to 1 6 to 2 6. once again we end
up at point b